everyone likes free games and now we
know what we're getting from PlayStation
next month I'm Tony this is a game spot
news update and this is your PlayStation
Plus August lineup first up ps4 players
are getting rebel galaxy a spacefaring
game with lots of trading and combat
they're also getting tricky towers which
is a bit like Tetris but with the goal
of stacking your blocks as high as
possible ps3 players are getting their
own space adventure with retrograde a
rhythm game where time flows backwards
they're also getting Yakuza 5 which
originally brought the Japanese mob to
the ps3 last year and on PS Vita you'll
get patapon 3 the last of the rhythm /
war series finally twin stick shooter
ultra tron is coming to all three
platforms any of those sound good to you
these PS plus games will be available
Tuesday August second you have until
then to grab July's games including fury
and fat princess and if you're trying to
keep up with all the latest from
PlayStation you're already in the right
place